et maintenant d'accueil sonia dubois
[Musique]
jeudi une lettre de jeanine presse
jeanine a des problèmes avec ses gros
lolos elle fait du sens et du sens et du
sens et oui l'occuper et vas-y m alors
alors pas d'homme pas de sport pas de
fantaisie rien du tout mais c'est plus
une vie c'est un vrai calvaire alors
jeanine écoutez moi vous allez relever
les épaules bomber le torse et vous
sanglé la taille dans une ceinture
vous avez des sales affaires palais hier
dans vie à nos mannequins fil de fer
alors puisque vous les avez en au but
comme marilyn
oui jayne mansfield et lollobrigida et
ben vous allez me jeter au feu cette
espèce de paires de gants de toilette en
tulle blindés
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
sonia dubois rive gauche à paris comme
chaque matin l'ex chroniqueuse emmène
son fils hippolyte est la crèche vous
savez dans la vie tout est ritualisée
depuis que j'ai mon bébé d'abord tous
fait à l'heure il se rallie tous les
jours à la même heure on produit pour la
même heure après la télé le dada de
sonia aujourd'hui âgé de 48 ans cessons
enfin déposez mont bellevue à la crèche
c'est un truc que je fais pour lui avec
la conscience que que c'est bien qu'il
faut aller dans la vie qu'après tout
fait ce jour à l'école
pour moi c'est une culpabilité
abominable hippolyte entre de bonnes
mains
sonia retrouve son mari à l'heure du
petit déjeuner pour deux jeunes parents
tout tourne autour de leurs enfants ont
parfois c'est pas violent mais à hassaï
gueule à la maison loin on est d'accord
sur ya en gros on est du sud continue
suite voilà plutôt oui je suis du nord
du sud finit le rythme un peu foufou de
la télé sonia profite désormais de son
temps libre pour faire du lèche vitrines
et dévoré les livres de cuisine est
absolument pas la cuisine mais j'assume
les nombreuses baies de billes en
revanche j'ai chez moi des bouquins de
cuisine tous plus beaux les uns que les
autres parce que je lis ça ou comme un
roman ou comme un livre d'art en fin de
matinée retour à l'appartement familial
à voler facture il est temps de
travailler
ah ça c'est une maison avec un bébé à
yalu fully comme habite au
rez-de-chaussée donc on a eu
l'impression d'habiter dans une petite
maison
et puis polita deux petites copines
concept ans et 3 ans une fois que vous
entendez ça
[Applaudissements]
désormais sonia dubois est auteur mais
là encore hippolyte n'est pas très loin
je travaille donc en ce moment avec papa
d'icônes it on fait des chroniques
rembourser sur la vie notre bébé mais la
vie de notre bébé sous laon de parents
qu'on 50 ans après l'écriture sonia se
consacre à son second métier
ambassadrice pour jenny craig un
programme minceur qui comprend à la fois
nutrition forme et bien-être à
l'habitude d'être je vous appelle mais
jerry ou un modèle je sais j'ai
conscience que j'emmène derrière moi ces
femmes et ces hommes qui ont décidé de
massira ça c'est ça n'a pas de prix
nous retrouvons sonia quelques semaines
plus tard toujours en plein coeur du
quartier latin quarter littéraire
aujourd'hui elle se prépare à la lecture
d'une pièce avec la metteur en scène
isabelle rattier modulable à voter quand
je te vois c'est le soleil de petits
cafés les cafés de vernon avec sonia on
a fait comme ça qu'on s'est rencontrés
on a fait ce qui est venu faire
agen assez formidable
la rencontre professionnelle et l'icann
ce qu'il faut je ferai des progrès alors
je t'ai fait les deux que tu m'avais
demandé la sortie au théâtre et la
lettre d'amour est quand même la lettre
d'amour c'est quand même extraordinaire
la lettre d'amour unique le 33 janvier
1925 et michel chef les marrons pleure
je prends dans mes mains mon porte plume
et je t'écris c'est bien tu vas le faire
j'essaye de faire en fait se fait plus
encore suivre deux sens en pleurs je
prends vous portent plus victimes et de
l'intérieur 1 2 le havre d'accord du
simple que ça on dit au revoir ma puce
bonne mise en scène auteur égérie
actrice et maman vais chercher mon petit
garçon à la crèche on vient jouer là
sonia pourrait également très bientôt
monter sur scène pour un one woman show
maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
celui du gard bienvenue sur le plateau
de tout le monde en parlait alors sonia
vous êtes né le 20 octobre 1963 à
combrée de parents épicier fromagers
alors un essence déjà un gros bébé ou
fait 5 kg 1
et ensuite vous êtes une petite fille
ronde trop ronde à 11 ans vous impose un
régime drastique avec prise
d'amphétamines
est ce que ces prix du frag à mort du
médiateur enfin toutes ces substances
non parce qu'à l'époque il n'existait
pas j'ai pris ce qui était à l'époque
interdit maintenant qui s'appelle le
dinantais l'île dont les conséquences
neurologiques et et eric terrible alors
à l'époque il n'est pas question de
psychologie on dit elle mange trop dont
il faut qu'elle mange moi je viens ya
pas de ya pas de prise en charge
ah ben aucune on est dans une époque
absolument cartésienne où l'esprit n'a
rien à voir avec le corps mes parents
sont des gens qui travaillent dans un
métier de bouche donc fatalement ils
n'ont pas d'autorité sur moi ce qui
percute pas mis dix ans pour eux et elle
bouffe trop
donc elle est grosse alors le problème
c'est qu'après tous ses essais à la fin
de votre adolescence
ah là là je deviens omez période de
l'enfant ronde que j'étais je suis
essoufflée déjà dans les régimes à 18
ans et là ça va devenir tragique en fin
tragique
oui ap alors donc vous avez une enfance
pas gai quoi vous est ronde vous portez
des normes hublot vous êtes au
pensionnat où on vous fait bien sentir
que vos parents ne sont que des petits
commerçants et vous vous rêvez d'être si
si absolument
qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras grande sogno avec oui c'est vrai
que même avec vos kilos volume des
dettes appareil dentaire votre cheveu
sur la langue
quand vous vous regardez dans la glace
vous vous dites quand je serai grande je
serai connu je pense que simone signoret
avait raison quand elle elle disait je
mets au défi
une seule petite fille au monde à cinq
ans de dire autre chose que mais je veux
être reconnu et connu au sens pas connu
comme maintenant mais vedette de cinéma
alors à 15 ans vous rêvez d'être
espionne vous partez apprendre le russe
à valenciennes et puis vous lancer dans
des études de philo et c'est pendant ses
études de philo qu'en jouant les
animatrices sur radio arc en ciel une
station locale de lille vous tomber
amoureuse de christophe qui est le
régisseur de la station de radio en fait
tout à fait qui lui
et aussi mieux que moi plus brillants
quand même parce qu'il a fait subir un
tel gain de grandes écoles et je trouve
ce gars font à briand et ça me fait
depuis thierry voilà en 1985 et 22 ans
vous marier tous les deux à cambrai et à
l'époque vous dit le divorce est une
chose absolument inenvisageable pour moi
donc c'est vraiment marié pour la vie
quoi là vous quitter le nord pour paris
vous venez faire votre doctorat de philo
c'est assez trapu parce que votre thèse
c'est le concept d'unité chez levinas et
derrida à c'était l'unité est justement
ce qui n'était pas l'unité parce que
l'un et l'autre on travaillait justement
sur l'éparpiller et l'unité comme vous
alors vous vous raterez l'agrégation que
vous êtes passionné de mode vous préféré
couvrir les défilés avec vos amis
stylistes est vrai très très branché
mode est là en attendant vous vous
lancer dans le journalisme en fin de
journée vous faites le courrier des
lecteurs
a télé caf était à tv câble est d'eau et
là un jour dans une fête du beaujolais
nouveau à mon mari
vous croisez nathalie cote du magazine
glamour qui vous demande de participer à
une séance photo pour son magazine sur
les rondes
voilà et là christine bravo tombe sur
lui amour miracle vous êtes invités dans
l'avant dernière émission de merci
encore bravo et puis vous êtes engagés
pour froufrous et voilà c'est le miracle
ça c'est extraordinaire
alors au début nous fait un peu le
courrier des lecteurs domfront froome et
après vous faites la mode et moi je me
souviens de vous voilà vous appeliez
gauthier pour vous c'était jean paul
quoi s'étaient tous vos amis vous les
connaissiez
c'était extraordinaire parce que je les
regardais thierry avec ce regard de
petite fille de province qui a la chance
de les rencontrer et j'étais à la fois
admirative de leur travail parce que ce
sont vraiment des artistes et et
admirative de de ben si tu être c'est à
dire d'avoir eu la chance de pouvoir les
côtoyer
c'est alors là vous devenez star
l'émission de ta un gros carton faut
dire c'est énorme c'est arrivé assez
vite finalement votre célébrité non mais
quirion
on fait la première émission j suis pas
parce que vraiment ce n'était pas
votable montrable la deuxième et je
crois qu'à la 4e toutes les filles on
était connu sa gaieté il y avait la
jolie l'assassinât prola l'écrit
d'écriture celle qui avait une plume et
la crosse et c'était reparti mais c'est
vrai quelle a été la réaction de votre
entourage à ce moment là alors ma mère
et mon frère étaient absolument ravi
mais à aimer avec ce ravissement naïf
des gens chez qui en a un qui qui
réussit papa était fou de rage parce
qu'il trouvait que je ressemblais à un
de ses personnages de cinéma italien qui
détestent et il voulait pas du tout je
donne cette image là deux mois sous
terre que mon père me rêve est vraiment
au 20h de 20h fait de la télé c'est pour
faire 21 minimum donc cette petite
gaudriole ne le notre nom il a mis il a
mis du temps
et puis un jour je me suis aperçu que de
tous c'était lui qui découpait les
articles de journaux les photos tout ça
sans parler et christophe il a réagi
comment votre mari christophe fille là
je je crois qu'il a été prodigieux
prendre prodigieux de 2 retenu fut de
maîtrise
de reculer et en même temps je crois que
c'est quelqu'un qui vingt 20 ans durant
et avec le recul du temps maintenant je
comprends ça use m'a poussé toujours
seulement pour pousser quelqu'un coût de
l'énergie beaucoup
il faut faire abstraction de soi même en
plus alors quelles ont été vos relations
avec les médias à l'époque tout ce qui
était populaire sympa j'adorais il ya eu
un peu de choses trash que j'ai moins
aimé
on a cherché des choses pas très jolies
et puis il y avait un truc qui était
quand même qui a eu raison moi
d'ailleurs parce que j'étais jeune et je
ne connaissais rien à la faire on a
cherché à monter les fils les unes
contre les autres nations ça c'était
vraiment pas bien votre vie privée a
souffert de votre médiatisation je crois
thierry que j'en ai pas eu
j'en ai pas eu ça m'a la médiatisation
six jeunes pour quelqu'un qui n'était
absolument pas fait était très inhibante
en fait j'en ai pas eu
je pensais que c'était tellement
essentiel que c'était tellement
important que j'ai tout donné j'ai tout
donné vraiment vraiment j'en ai pas eu
j'ai raté sa vie privée oui j'ai été
mous frais complètement alors l'aventuré
au fond vous rapporter un peu d'argent
quand même à la rue je veux faire mais
on veut garder un peu j'avais gardé un
peu de choses jusqu'à mon divorce alors
le meilleur moment de cette époque
froufrous disons c'est quoi la liberté
la liberté d'avoir tiré les leçons et
christine bravo en face de moi qui me
disent
d'abord qu'ils me disent ok pour le
faire c'était pas gagné d'avancé
ok pour être déguisé ok pour faire un
faux pas c'était totalement burlesque
quand même des lions et sacchi berthet
cet envol là c'est merveilleux c'est
magique
le pire moment de l'époque c'était quoi
elles n'ont pas forcément été gentiment
oui c'était très dur tu y arrives pas
alors évidemment avait pas extrêmement
populaire parce que vous êtes la
première grosse dame que les gens voient
dans le poste qu'il faut dire c'est que
c'était avant marianne james avant
boccolini avant damidot vous étiez la
première qu'on mettait à la télé quoi
j'ai été la première il ya eu un premier
noir ya une première barrette et bahia
une première croatie ça voilà dans les
minorités visibles j'étais ce grand bien
et pourquoi ça s'est arrêté bravo et
vous je vous le dire alors c'est bêta
comme tout guy job à l'époque réalise
une émission pour tf1 qui doit pas être
concurrents directs qui s'appelle
histoire d'en rire et je vais raconter
une blague et je le dis pas et je le dis
pas et bravo mais il est équipé qui pour
pas me dire que ses reins et sam
ça monte ça monte ça monte ça monte et
ça explose enfin ça dure dix secondes
enfin ça s'est passé comme ça et ça
s'est passé comme ça pays rattrape avec
ça christine parce que christine holla
holla très hésitante alors été 94 est
chroniqueur dans deux quoi j'ai l'air
avec gérard holtz sur france 2 vous
retombez pas mal sur vos pâtes
finalement allé à l'époque mais pourtant
vous faites une grosse déprime sur la
plage vous vous apercevez que vous posez
130 kg vous dites je suis une baleine
échouée quoi sert que je suis passé des
90 15 sympathique encore vivables
rondouillarde chez christina a
franchement quelqu'un dont la première
chose qu'on dit mais en face à face et
et le pathologique et ça saigne voilà
alors de retour à paris votre rapport à
la nourriture devient morbide un petit
peu comme dans la grande bouffe vous
mangez du matin au soir vous suicider en
bout froid comme andréa ferréol dans le
film et vous sombrez un peu dans le flou
mais à ce moment là vous savez thiery je
pense que passé un certain nombre de
calories par jour
on libère des endorphines on est comme
quelqu'un qui prend une drogue forme
d'ailleurs c'est une vibration c'est une
drogue est effroyable parce que c'est
comme l'alcool 1 en trouve à tous les
coins de rue successeur le problème bien
sûr et ça coûte moins cher que les
drogues dites on se lance chic et
et je vis d'abord je vais coucher les la
plupart du temps et je ne fais que
manger et tout m'apparaît tout m'arrive
comme amicaux le monde m'arrive comme un
écho aux perses essence vous savez je
vais vous souvenez du conseil d'un ami
attachée de presse qui vous avez dit tu
devrais essayer la clinique perfect line
voilà alors vous arrivé à la clinique
aux champs elysées vous dégouliner laon
qui me pesait 130 kg le tournage quoi et
vous expliquer aux toubibs voulait
perdre 60 kg c'est dans la moitié de
votre boîte pour rien dans la main c'est
plus que le poids de beaucoup de femmes
68 c'est ça au départ tout le monde me
dit écoute et perdez entre entre venais
déjà donc pas une normalité mort à
quelque chose de vivable pour vous et
puis on verra en 95 l'objectif est
atteint mais alors que vous revenez à la
télé est une question vous tourmente
comment va réagir le public en voyant la
nouvelle sonia dubois la semaine du bois
mince presque presque maigre et vous
dites je devais bientôt me rendre compte
que quelque chose était cassée quoi vous
savez tirer on trahit jamais ce les
siens la vie la vie c'est pas
intellectuel la vie c'est viscéral c'est
plein d'empathie c'est plein de
ressentiment de ressentis et
et pour les femmes j'étais populaire
parce que j'étais ronde et que quelque
part je racontais à toute une partie de
leur vie dont des enfants des ennuis et
j'avais celui là qui étaient visibles
ont été sympa tu me n'y voyez aucun
égotisme ça me rendait sympathique et
voilà que je trahissais voilà que je
rentrais dans la norme donc qu'est ce
qu'il allait advenir de moi et beaucoup
beaucoup l'ont dit alors voilà désormais
vous n'êtes plus là la rigolote dodu de
froufrous mais la femme qui a perdu 60
kg
donc ça ça vous catégorise autres
membres c'est à dire qu'à partir de ce
moment là beaucoup d'autres vont aussi
me demander comment je fais 1 1 et va
commencer une autre partie du chemin
alors voilà ensuite vous referai de la
télé mais disons jamais avec le même
succès que froufrous vous passez
beaucoup de temps à l'étranger aussi à
l'époque ce qui n'arrange rien ce qui
n'aide pas parce que vous expatrier à
cause du travail de votre mari
christophe et puis en 2006 c'est le coup
de grâce après 23 ans de vie commune
christophe vous met à la porte
ça a été violent très violent
je crois sincèrement qu'on s'en remet
jamais on continue mais au sort mais pas
qu'avec des mots en plus qu'ils sont
ah oui ça a été très dur très violent
on retrouve à la rue oui je suis à la
rue sur des bons voisins des jets
heureusement je retombe sur mes pattes
au théâtre donc c'est les amazones et
celle d'amazon mais les amazones ont
sauvé et heureusement quelqu'un les
amazones parce que sinon vous auriez
coulé à pic
bah oui parce que je fais partie de ces
gens cons qui veulent pas ennuyer leurs
parents serge josé pas du tout le dire à
mes parents mais je me demande ce que je
serais devenu les beaux parents on en
rien su mes parents ont su que j'allais
bien quand je suis allé mieux
d'accord mais non ils n'ont pas si leur
épargner ça alors ce qui n'a rien
arrangé c'est votre participation à une
émission de télé réalité de tf1 qui
s'appelle je suis une célébrité sortez
moi de là et c'était dans la jungle du
heureusement nous étions brésil à côté
de teresopolis
oui ça non ça ne vas y et thierry danse
danse qu'on ne doit pas faire dans une
vie y est fin et depuis vous avez du mal
à recevoir des propositions de d'emplois
depuis cette téléréalité de télé j'en ai
pas et ça me
ça m'ennuie ouais ça m'ennuie
profondément
heureusement il ya le théâtre ah oui à
45 ans vous êtes toujours sur les
planches et puis la joie d'être maman
c'est extraordinaire ce que vous était
arrivé parce que à 45 ans quand même
vous dites c'est un bébé miracle je ne
devais pas avoir d'enfant je devais pas
avoir d'enfant parce que j'avais une
pathologie assez lourde jeunes
donc c'est eux s'étaient fait alors ça
pour le coup s'était améliorée vous en
avez pris votre parti vraiment c'est mc
parise et moi c'était un anglais et
voilà que ça m'arrive ça c'est sublime
maintien alors aujourd'hui sony est ce
que vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque
fou fou je crois tu irais je suis né
mélancolique
donc oui oui bien sûr que oui parce
qu'on avait 20 ans parce que ça marchait
parce que ça marchait parce que c'était
comme nulle part ailleurs de connaux
gildas apparemment léger et plein de
travail vous avez de la rancune par
exemple contre christine à l'épaule vous
avoir viré comme ça sur un claquement de
doigts où l'on voulait non mais
j'aimerais qu'un jour on se revoit et
qu'on se dise que maintenant on est
vieille et et qu' il faut même
humainement pas c'est sûr ça ça serait
bien oh là ça serait bien si c'était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil sonia j'aurais été plus
pugnace je ne ferai pas partie à chaque
fois que quelque chose n'allait pas je
me trouve assez lâches
souvent j'ai baissé les bras ils
trouveront par exemple vous pensez que
si vous étiez réimposer vous auriez pu
rester dans l'émission oui je pense
qu'il fallait être comme elle elle
cherchait pas un oui bien sûr le jour
vous allez mourir qu'elle voulait qu'on
écrive sur votre tombe
c'était une chic fille j'aurais dû le
rappeler
merci c'est un trésor est la lumière sur
vous pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus